welcome to this video that's a blitz
game against the Rainmaker from Estonia
this is Olaf zip right that's all right
let me check yep Olaf zip let's see we
get the field chatter variation the
Kings Indian and he's playing the old
main line okay yeah nowadays they go see
5am is there something else that I can
play I'm not really knowing this too
well why at all rookie one this is
possible playing sort of position ollie
I think 98 yes sir this is this is how
it is played how is this is done might
be three hear something like that or
where do I go with a 19 probably here
yeah yeah yeahs vaguely remember it's
been a while Bishop here yeah and a for
SF is bound to come I think there is
some some point sacrifice
83 takes bishop f1 back then back to e
694 queen is seven ok somehow I don't
really know how this is supposed to it's
supposed to be okay but there's a for a
three threatened yeah it's not a good
thing if you have to find all this over
the board hmm oh no one Knight d4 as
possible try to sort of track the Queen
Queen a six probably
yeah wow this is bad yep spending like
two minutes for theoretical position
that the opponent seems to know in and
out oh man that's a bit of bit of a bad
start yet to get get get to this okay so
how do we continue here is going to play
95 yes not quite so clear where my
compensation is him against the city six
porn okay i don't know i need to be a
bit quicker 93 i can take and push up f1
trapping the Queen I think I can take on
d4 then even but but still I need to to
speed up you know this is time
disadvantage will will be an issue how
do I continue maybe f53 for this is kind
of thing it gives up the five square but
I need to get something going here night
c2 to be for this is leading nowhere
really at least he is catching up on the
clock of it yeah 93 sm is tempting okay
okay need to need to do something at
least take away some crucial squares it
gives up a five but it also clocks up
his coordination a little bit
yeah if it's possible g4 g5f six yeah
but not so easy it'd be great for him if
he got in Knight to e5 but this was not
possible
now need to catch up on the clock really
just play a bit quicker I wonder about
Bishop Aoife Bishop f4 if this might be
a move find to exchange this now maybe I
also can think of Bishop f1 all the time
Bishop f1 queen bee 6mm is it's in a in
a sensitive diag in a little bit maybe I
should ok first of all we'll take this
temple anyway I he can go here but
nothing nothing I can do about it um
should f1 yeah I'm still to be six maybe
here and then intending Knight f3 Knight
f3 to attack the bishop
ok now that we will take c3m so this is
not not working but 92 is a move 92 93
maybe
92 93
yeah something something like that may
be protecting be to soil i have bishop
everyone some sometime and maybe I can
do something on the F file it's super
complicated of course
ok now I'm going to do this tending
Bishop c5 and what is he doing now I
mean this is this is really threatening
and rook f1 Brooke md one may be coming
this was one idea of the doubling the
guy hd7 bishop is now under pressure ok
I have to connect I guess ok do I get
maybe Bishop f3 coming playing on the on
the night
now night g 7 f-6 this is starting to to
be a bit tricky really tricky queen age
six is now a possible IDM to attack yeah
but it's not not decisive or anything
mmm how do i do I get forward here to
that mark I'm my queen is also offside
in a way my team Knight to f3 or
something to to attack the bishop I
don't know what it's probably it
probably is good for black the whole
thing twin h6 didn't lead to much I
think at least
yeah now that this was probably well
played out what he did here
green age six now maybe intending to
take on via take here first and queen of
sixes you can go back rat okay you
wonder still protected six seconds
that's not good light for faiths whole
time yeah some City Times stuff at the
end yeah blah what a game yeah I mean I
caught up with this big time
disadvantage but i really was struggling
with the pawn down it is some I don't
know how to help this opening it is
definitely a theoretical position here
definitely okay now now I need to do
this not f4 I need to do this okay this
is what I forgot f6 yeah this is no no
Bishop f1 is threatened and I think
Queen a six is not really good so yeah
because I have this one this is a
problem here is falling apart completely
so this is the GM and now now i remember
i know that there was this f6 Queen f7
black hair to to to do making sure to
make some sort of concession and here
white really has some compensation in
the game
not so much really he didn't need to
play f6 and and I was really struggling
trying to to get something going it was
yeah computer is basically giving black
a winning position all the way he has
this pawn and yeah I'm I have weakened
myself a lot but I need to do something
cannot just just just shuffle around and
he always kept the the winning hand I
mean can write to the to the very NTA
one final position of causes i think i
just have the cornea and then twin but
yeah we should be five and major and
everything but ok this is the silly five
minute stuff not without any increment
so there is no logical end too many
games I mean okay he was always winning
but the final position of course he had
he had given away with no time on the
clock yeah yeah this was really an
opening and opening problem I don't I
don't have any any good position here
and it's really like that it looks lines
from optical born of here we have the
center but there is nothing that I can
attack here and yeah it would have been
probably a very clear business if he had
played a bit quicker even okay thanks
for watching